[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
diese leckeren nuss hörnchen und die
könnt ihr mit nur sechs zutaten
zubereiten die ihr eigentlich auch alle
zu hause da haben müsste also nichts wie
ran an den ofen und ich zeige euch jetzt
erst mal das was wir benötigen
für den schnellen und unkomplizierten
teig benötigen wir mehl butter und
doppel ram frischkäse die genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch unten in
die infobox und wir starten damit in dem
wir alle drei zutaten mit den händen
miteinander vermengen
die mutter ist bei mir nicht ganz so
kalt ich habe sie etwa eine stunde
vorher aus dem kühlschrank geholt und
jetzt knete ich das ganze zu einem
schönen kompakten teig
der tag ist noch etwas klebrig und das
ist auch ganz normal
deshalb nehmen wir ihn jetzt aus der
schüssel ich hätte den dann noch gerne
auf der arbeitsfläche ein wenig dann
habe ich ein besseres gefühl dafür und
dann wirklich das in frischhaltefolie 1
[Musik]
den teig gebe ich dann für zirka eine
stunde in den kühlschrank damit der
härter wird und man ihn anschließend
besser aus rollen kann
[Musik]
und jetzt zeige ich euch drei weitere
zutaten die wir benötigen das es ein mal
weiße zucker brauner zucker und gehackte
haselnüsse die drei zutaten für den
belag werden miteinander verrührt und
dann ist ja auch schon fertig und es
gibt weiter mit unserem gekühlten teig
den gekühlten teig nehme ich jetzt aus
der frischhaltefolie und teile ihnen
durch zwei so dass sich zuallererst mit
der einen hälfte beginnen kann
[Musik]
den teig kneten ich mir ein paar
sekunden lang noch mal geschmeidig und
dann freue mich ihn zu einer kugel gebe
auf die arbeitsfläche den belag dem wir
uns gerade an gemischt haben und dann
rolle ich die kugel darin aus
[Musik]
während des aufräumens bleiben die
zucker und haselnuss stückchen darin
haften und das ist das was uns den
geschmack bringt deshalb ist der teig
auch nicht gesucht denn wir haben den
zucker ja dann quasi auf dem teig und
drehte es auch immer wieder um damit
auch jede seite voll mit dem belag ist
[Musik]
nachdem der teig dann ca 1 cm dicke
ausgerollt wurde schneide ich ihn in
acht gleichmäßige stücke
[Musik]
und es ist auch gar nicht so schlimm
dass die stücke am ende nicht ganz so
rund sind das sieht man hinterher
sowieso nicht mehr so bald in die stücke
dann durchgeschnitten hatte fangt ihr
haben sie zu croissants zurollen
[Musik]
startet dafür auf der breiten seite und
rollt es nach innen bis hin zur spitze
[Musik]
das gleiche mache ich jetzt auch mit
meiner zweiten hälfte und so erhaltet
ihr insgesamt 16 schöne und leckere nuss
hörnchen
sie kommen dann auf ein mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech und werden bei 190
grad für 16 bis 18 minuten gebacken bis
sie schön goldbraun sind das tolle daran
ist dass der braune zucker im ofen
karamellisiert und ihr dann ein richtig
lecker muss sich kollegen geschmack
erhaltet falls ihr jetzt auch lust
bekommen habt auf diese leckeren nushöhr
und dann macht es gerne nachlass dem
video einen daumen nach oben da und
abonniert doch gerne meinen kanal und
ich sage bis zum nächsten mal auf
münchens kitchen
[Musik]